[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos con mayra oyola elle
científica atmosférica del laboratorio
de propulsión a chorro muchas gracias
señora oyola por esta comunicación la
nasa publicó ya los datos de temperatura
global para el 2020 donde se ubica el
año anterior en el ranking de
temperaturas globales y que nos dice
esta nueva información sobre las
tendencias en la temporada de huracanes
tras las 30 tormentas que batieron
récords el año pasado
lo primero que es todo buenos días a
todos saludos desde el estado de
california en eeuu como bien has dicho
ambas agencias no vainas han actualizado
este registro de temperatura y lo que
nos está diciendo es que el año pasado
el año 2020 ha empatado con el 2016 como
el año más caliente en este récord este
registró una de las cosas que tenemos
que tener en consideración es que no
debemos solamente observar el estado
número para el año pasado pero ver cuál
es la tendencia a largo plazo y cuando
vemos esta tendencia vemos un
calentamiento acelerado especialmente
los últimos 7 años que han sido los 7
años más calientes en este récord
e información específica sobre los
incendios forestales estos récords que
también se alcanzaron el año anterior
si nosotros especialmente en el área de
eeuu y también en australia observamos
una gran cantidad de algún evento
histórico de hecho en cuanto a los
fuegos forestales para el área oeste de
eeuu vivimos unos 10.3 millones de acres
que fueron devorados por estos fuegos
forestales y vamos a continuar viendo
actividades o eventos de esta categoría
a medida que las temperaturas vayan
aumentando
precisamente porque vamos a tener todas
estas condiciones que pueden conducir a
fuegos forestales más intensos y que se
expandan mucho más rápido como hemos
visto tenemos un problema de sequía en
el área oeste de eeuu y esto obviamente
también contribuye al deshielo y
contribuye eventualmente también a ver
los fuegos forestales señora oyola y de
qué otras maneras no se afectan los
cambios en la temperatura global de la
tierra
y estamos interconectados así que vamos
a ver cambios a medida que estas
temperaturas van aumentando cambios a
niveles globales y cambios a niveles
regionales a niveles globales una de las
cosas que nos tienen muy preocupados a
nosotros los científicos es el
derretimiento de la capa del ártico esto
es lo que está creando es un efecto
dominó porque las temperaturas en estas
áreas están calentándose tres veces
mucho más rápidos que nosotros áreas del
mundo lo cual sigue promoviendo este
derretimiento de cada pasito y por ende
si se vivimos con este efecto dominó a
esto a su vez a ayudar o no a aumentar
estos niveles de océanos a niveles
marítimos lo cual es un problema
sumamente importante o algo que no no
podemos pasar por desapercibido que
podemos esperar ver en el futuro en
términos de temperaturas o eventos
meteorológicos globales
una de las cosas que tenemos que tener
en consideración como he dicho es bien
importante en ver a este este patrón a
largo plazo y posiblemente en los
próximos años vamos a ver quizás que en
algunos de estos años el número parece
años es un poco más bajo que este año
pero por lo general lo que estamos
viendo es una tendencia a que estas
temperaturas están aumentando están
aumentando de forma rápida y esto va a
afectar por ejemplo patrones de
precipitación a patrones de sequía
huracanes la intensidad de estos
huracanes y cuando a frecuentes se están
formando
nos quedan 40 segunditos señora oyola
que debe priorizar la sociedad la
ciudadanía los gobiernos y las empresas
me parece que en este momento lo más
importante que tenemos que tener en
cuenta es educarnos educarnos sobre que
realmente es el cambio
global y como nosotros podemos educarnos
a los otros y a otros a otras personas
de nuestra población para tomar las
decisiones más adecuadas pues muchas
gracias a mayra oyola elle científica
atmosférica del laboratorio de
propulsión a chorro que nos dio las
recomendaciones sobre la publicación de
la nasa en los datos de la temperatura
global del 2020 y ustedes muchas gracias
por su compañía los invitamos a seguir
con nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]